all right price where are we at around
low 40 thousands yeah so like the first
chart you'll see are just some price
levels i drew out so
last week we talked about i had started
buying around 41k
um and the reasoning is just because
i saw a 40k is just a you know really
clear kind of macro support level it was
a prior higher low that we hadn't
retested yet
and so you know at a minimum you should
be expecting a bounce off of the first
three test of a macro higher low so
did start buying as i talked about last
week got a nice little reaction off of
that
and now it appears that we were setting
some kind of higher low um posted this
this morning or took the screenshot of
the chart this morning at like 40 to 500
from there from this area that i was
looking at for a little uh bounce or you
know a little micro kind of higher lower
here um we have seen a little bounce up
to what are we at now like 43 to 200 so
i've seen like a nice little seven eight
hundred dollar bounce off that area so
it does look like we're sitting a little
higher low here on kind of
microstructure which is a good sign of
course um you know i'm still chilling in
spot
i think the first area to look at is
this prior range low um call that around
like 46k to be specific like 45 7
and see kind of how derivatives look
there um and then from there you know if
let's say you know it looks like you
know perps perhaps are fading the the
rally then you know maybe we get a
little move up to prior range highs but
i'm just kind of playing it level to
level um for now but yeah still chilling
in in my spot bias that we talked about
last week but yeah this is just what i'm
looking at from you know purely just a
price structure standpoint
all right so that makes a lot of sense
in terms of where we are right now one
of the things that you've been talking
about for a while now
that has maybe not concerned but like is
definitely worth paying attention to is
this open interest and in today's
newsletter
you call out that it's still high so
explain
why this is important for people to
understand and what this potentially
could mean in terms of volatility in the
future
yeah so last week i felt like we that
might have been the longest that we've
ever recorded we went pretty in-depth in
terms of um describing open interest and
funding and some of these you know
derivatives metrics
but you know for anyone maybe who wasn't
listening last week open interest at a
high level is just
if you want like a bit more nuanced
explanation you know feel free to look
at last week's video i just don't want
to like reiterate it for people that
were listening last week um yeah open
interest is just looking at the amount
of open contracts so there's you know
always balanced out in terms of how many
longs and shorts there are open interest
just tells you how many of those
contracts are open um and so we we are
still in this kind of
uh area where you know prior pro you
know previously the last four or five
times that we've been in this upper area
we have seen a flush after that so it's
basically showing you like this is a an
area where you know open interest is
building up sufficiently that you know
you get some kind of wipe out and that's
not necessarily a bullish or bears thing
um you know as as we've seen in may you
know that was a
a sign that you know longs are really
aggressive we got to wipe out the end of
summer though you know those aggressive
shorts that built up and so we had a
short squeeze so it's just telling you
that
the contracts are built up but it
doesn't tell you about the positioning
so we still do have a lot of leverage
built up as you can see in the last like
kind of 24 hours we've actually started
to wipe out a little bit of the open
interest on this move up
um and so perhaps that you know it's
showing you that you know uh shorts are
starting to close out on this move up
um but yeah i mean we're still still
very high we still wiped out a minuscule
amount of oi compared to what we've
built up over the last month you know
call it like uh maybe like a fifth of
the oi we've built up over the last
month so yeah still expecting some
volatility in that sense
and some some you know major kind of
liquidation event that we've been
talking about for a while but you know
i'm still waiting on it i keep i keep
posting like on my twitter like when
when squeeze that's yeah that's what i'm
referring to i'm just waiting for this
metric to wipe out of this kind of
overheated area